I
so many of you who have played or even
just watched the recent code of war
would have seen Santa Monica Studios
Tizen and acknowledging other
mythological worlds in one of Tears
murals but we see symbols are present in
other mythologies on the top left we see
the Eye of Horus or the eye of Raw
representing Egyptian mythology on the
top right we see the Greek letter Omega
on the bottom left we see the Japanese
2mo symbol which is also heavily used in
Shinto religion and lastly on the bottom
right we have the Celtic Triskelion
seeing all of these symbols together in
the same place has led many to speculate
where the franchise could go next once
the Norse world has run its course and
in this video I'd like to discuss what
we could see in these different
Pantheon's were I would personally like
to see God of War go next and of course
leave an open forum for you guys to
discuss what you would like to see next
so Sodom of the obvious first as much as
I'd like to see God of War returned to
Greek mythology I think most people
would like to see something new so it's
safe to assume that we most likely won't
be returning to the Greek world any time
soon I do think there are a lot of
people who want to see Kratos take on
the Egyptian Pantheon but there are a
few reasons I prefer God of all not to
go to Egypt right away my first concern
be know it's been done quite often by
games with it most recently been the
location for the last Assassin's Creed
where we did see it all of the Egyptian
Pantheon and it did do really well
my second concern and the main reason I
think Santa Monica Studios should avoid
Egypt as of right now is the lack of
creatures and monsters that feature an
Egyptian mythology for me one of the
main reasons the previous games worked
so well is because of the balance
between gods and monsters that Kratos
had to battle now on a positive note I
think Kratos encountering the likes of
rah set Anubis
sobic and many of the other Egyptian
deities would make for some epic
cinematics and boss fights so this isn't
me saying that I don't want God of all
to ever visit Egypt but rather there are
a few other regions I'd like to see it
visit first now I'm sure many of you are
excited at the prospect of god of war
taking place in Japan and it does offer
us endless possibilities the Japanese
and Shinto Pantheon's are quite large
with hundreds of yokai and spirits to be
slain there are also some rather
interesting monsters and animals such as
the kerydin the Tengu and of course the
Oni that would make for some great
gaming experiences and we've yet to even
mention the possibility of ninjas and
samurais in the game I definitely would
love to see God of War tackle Japanese
mythology and folklore and it is pretty
difficult to imagine Kratos in a kimono
but that alone for me would make the
game
buying so lastly we have Celtic
mythology which is at the top of my list
of where I think God of War should go
next having recently delved into Celtic
and Irish mythology this year it's been
extremely interesting and there are so
many creatures and monsters that could
fit straight into God of War we also
know that in Irish mythology Island is
being constantly invaded by supernatural
beings gods and creatures now throwing
Kratos in between one of these wars
between say the Tour de Delon and the
four mauryans would definitely have a
God of War field to it the idea of
Kratos clashing of the Morrigan is
something I'd love to see and there's
definitely no shortage of gods and
heroes for Kratos is slain the Irish
Pantheon I love all the mythologies
we've mentioned today Celtic and Irish
are definitely the least covered and the
least known so having a game like god of
war shrine sunlight on them would
definitely be awesome as I mentioned at
the start of the video I do look forward
to hearing what everyone else would like
to see what region do you want God of
War to explore next and is there a
particular creature or god that you're
excited about kratos encountering that
is if Kratos remains the poster boy of
the franchise let me know in the
comments below